mennyire gyakori hogy halállal
találkozol
hát nem mondanám hogy gyakoribb
feltétlen mint egy átlagos
belgyógyászati osztályon még akkor is
hogyha rossz indulatú
betegségekkel foglalkozom mert
hogy nem nagyobb a halálozási rátája de
hogy az én szakmában az én szakmámban a
halálozási ráta nagyon-nagyon alacsony
úgyh hogy kz nem alacsony tehát egyik
szakmában se alacsony mert hogyha
belegondolsz akkor az élet része az hogy
meghalunk tehát hogy megszülettünk és
valahol ott benne van előbb-utóbb a az
öreggedés következtében is hogy hogy
meghalunk igen de aki aki már közelebb
kerül akkor orvoshoz kerül nem nem
programozóhoz úgyhogyok úgyhogy ilyen
szempontból távoli és nek emlékszem
amikor az unokatestvéremmel történt ez
meg ő 25 éves volt és
egy egy egy trombózisa volt
valójában nagyon hamar
nagyon hamar történt minden engem
tragikusan ért engem lesújtott és és
akkor tehát akkor én is 26 éves voltam
vagy 27 talán és és emlékszem akkor ért
először ennyire közelről mer valahogy
úgy voltam vele hogy a halál az
megtörténik mással mással de velem nem
vagy az én környezetemel e nilván és
minél fiatalabban következik be akkor
annál inkább érint minket érzelmileg és
ez és ez a rendjén van mert hogy az
előbb mint mondtam a gyakorlatilag az
öregség lenne a normális halálok amit
ugye el tudnánk fogadni észszerűen és
nem egy fiatal korba
történt betegség vagy tragédia
baleset nem könnyű feldolgozni nem
könnyű feldolgozni a diagnózis se de nem
tudom feltétlen korhoz se kötni ezt hogy
amikor van egy egy rossz indulatú
diagnózis amivel szembesül a paciens
hogy az esetleg függne attól hogy fiatal
vagy öreg vagyok van úgy hogy 80
pluszosan igen azt mondja a beteg hogy
hát most már ideje de a legtöbbször
mégis azt tapasztaljuk hogy még az
unokám ér még a dédunokám ér tehát hogy
az élethez való ragaszkodás úgy gondolom
hogy ez egy természetes emberi érzés és
ezt úgy ez a normális hogy szeretünk
élni
h és akkor ez a fajta tragikus eset
amikor
valakinél egy rossz
indulatú esetet vélsz felfedezni ez ez
mennyire gyakori tehát hogy hetente
havonta igen azért hetente hetente és
akkor ilyenkor személyesen te mondod el
igen igen t igazából nincs ki elmondja
nincs és ez ez az orvos beteg
kapcsolatban úgy gondolom hogy ez a ez
az alap tehát hogy én kell közüljem a
beteggel tehát hetente előfordul hogy
ennyire súlyos kérdésekben kell beszélj
emberekkel ez mennyire terhel meg
érzelmileg
eléggé az elején talán még jobban
a pályafutásom elején akkor amikor
elveszítettünk egy-egy beteget még csak
nem is mondhattam hogy az én betegem
mert csak rezidensként voltam jelen
akkor a a
betegápolásba akkor úgy napokig akár
gyászoltam és akkor úgy volt egy
komolyabb beszélgetésünk a férjemmel
hogy akkor ezt így nem lehet csinálni és
döntsem el ahogy továbbott mert hogy az
ezzel számolni kell hogy a kórházban a
betegek meghalhatnak és hogy hogy nem
lehet mindenkit hetekig gyászolni jó
deát ezt meg tudja választani az ember
intellektuálisan én most nem akarom
gyászolni és nem fogod igen bizonyos
értelemben meg tudom választani azt hogy
érzelmileg mennyire kötődök egy-egy
beteghez valamennyire tehát hogy nem
tudjuk természetesen az egészzet kizárni
vagy egészen kizárni de tudatos
hogy mennyi információt akarok a
betegről a környezetéről a családjáról
azt úgy valamelyest tudom befolyásolni
és akkor tudok objektív maradni
szakmailag ha a a betegre és az ő
problémájára tudok koncentrálni és nem
arra hogy neki még otthon van három
gyereke aki ha ő most meghalárván marad
tehát hogy
igen azt látom hogy most is meg meg
megérint és egy-egy ilyenkor eszedbe jut
egy-egy konkrét eset igen igen tehát
hogy nem nem tudunk
elhatárolódni egészen és nem is kell úgy
gondolom hogy nem is kell tehát hogy nem
gépezeteket kezelünk hanem és te se egy
gép vagy igen nem egy cat gpt nem
valószínű nem is leszek pedig jó lenne
információ
szempontjából ez ez érdekes
mert ra nagyon érdekes az hogy az ember
képes arra hogy az élet tragédiájával
szembenézzen
hogy hogy képesek vagyunk a legnehezebb
pillanatban is felállni van aki
összeomlik van aki viszont feláll és nem
tudom megmondani mi a különbség a kettő
között ugyanaz az ember nem lehet így
kívülről kiszámolni hogy hogy ha ebben a
kontextusban van akkor biztos ezt fogja
csinálni szörnyű helyzetekben szörnyű
kontextusban emberek csodálatos módon
képesek voltak felállni és a legvégső
kik harc szólni
ezek ez számomra is egy követendő
csodálatos példa amire nem hiszem hogy
képes vagyok és ugyanakkor sokkal jobb
helyzetben levő embereket ismertem én
személyesen akik akik összeroppantak a a
sokkal kisebb súly alatt és ezek egyéni
életutak
egyéni egyéni hősöket termel magából ki
biztos vagyok benne hogy te is így a a
praxisod során találkoztál pár olyan
emberről akik hihetetlenül inspiráló
módon néztek szembe ezekkel a ezekkel a
a a tragikus hírekkel
igen végülis igen bár nem nem tudom nem
tudom hogy van-e olyan jó példa aki
emberként nem tud megrendíteni egy
tragédia tehát hogy valami baj van akkor
annak az embernek az érzelmi világával
ha nem tud téged megérinteni egy másik
embernek a
problémája én arról beszélek hogy a
saját problémát tehát hogy abban a
pillanatban amelyt megtudod hogy mármint
megtudom én tegy fel hogy van egy
halálos diagnózisom hogy hogyan állok
szembe ezzel a a hírrel el tudom
képzelni h van aki pánikba esik és és
van aki van aki elgondolkozik és azt
mondja hogy eljött a pillanat és ez az
életnek a természetes része úgyhogy
felkészülök arra hogy a lehetőle
méltóságteljesebben hagyja mit a a földi
létet nem tudom hogy ezekkel
találkozol-e ennyire közelről ak igen és
azt tapasztalom hogy a kezd kihalni ami
kultúránkb azt hogy
emberséggel tisztelettel otthon
szembenézni a
halállal hanem valamiért menekülünk
ennek a gondolatától nagyon sokszor azt
tapasztalom hogy bár
a beteg tudja a család tudja hogy hogy
meg fog halni mégsem akarja ezt otthon
végig csinálni együtt a család körében
hanem inkább beviszi a kórházba az
utolsó pillanataira
meghalni valami oknál fogva menekülünk a
ettől a történéstől az ismeretlentől nem
nem tudom mitől menekülünk egészen
pontosan megfogalmazni annyi biztos hogy
az a természetes módja hogy korábban
tapasztaltuk nagyszüleinknél hogy
elgondozták az ő nagyszüleiket vagy
szüleiket ez most már úgy kezd kikopni a
mi
társadalmunkból szeretnénk levenni ennek
a gondját ennek a lelki terhét vagy a
fizikai terhét is akár nem tudom
pontosan megfogalmazni hogy mit
szeretnénk mit ő szeretnék megszabadulni
amikor ez nagyon érdekes amit mondasz
hog ezek önként önként döntenek úgy hogy
inkább kórházban fognak igen igen igen
vagy
ped vagy akár családi nyomásra hogy
behozzák vagyom
hogy nem tudom miért nyilván hogy az is
egy egy szempont lehet hogy otthon nézni
tehetetlenül hogy szenved a
hozzátartozóm ez
eszméletlen és és nem tudok rajta
segíteni csak várjuk együtt a halált
tehát úgy gondolom hogy ennek a lelki
terhe ez ez óriási egy családra főleg
akkor hogyha ez egy gondoljunk bele egy
kétszabás tömbházlakásban ahol még még
lehet hogy gyerekek is vannak tehát hogy
gyakorlatilag az egész család szenved
ilyen értelemben úgy gondolom hogy egy
racionális lépés hogy a a hogy ez a
kórházba tudjon
megtörténni tehát am tehát ezelőtt 150
évvel amikorés igen valaki a a halálos
ágyán volt akkor akkor egy udvar volt
egy lakás kietett tényleg úgy
belegondolva hogy lehet hogy ott is két
szoba volt de volt egy nagyobb élettér
ahol lehetett létezni még igen igen
azért tényleg összezárva lenni ezek
komoly etikai kérdéseket vetnek fel